véronique proulx qui est pdg de
manufacturiers et exportateurs du québec
et stéphane drouet directeur général du
conseil québécois du commerce de détail
bonsoir à vous deux mois alors je vous
demande vos réactions madame courroux
d'abord écouter on pousse les
manufactures y poussent un soupir de
soulagement ce soir on est très heureux
de voir le premier ministre goadv connu
le secteur manufacturier dans son
ensemble pour l'essentiel au même titre
que c'est le fait en ontario aux états
unis partout ailleurs annoncé le site au
dollar au lendemain du statu quo
c'est-à-dire que d'autres d'autres
précisions qui sont attendus à savoir à
quoi à quoi fait référence le premier
ministre lorsqu'il nous dit que l'on
doit se fixer sur la production de biens
essentiels je pense qu'on doit avoir
davantage de précisions il ya un prime
abord c'est une excellente nouvelle mais
ne fait pas que vous ne le savez pas
encore c'est quoi
qu'est-ce que projet manufacturier où
nous in manufacturière une activité
manufacture est essentiel et une autre
activité qui ne pourra pas se poursuivre
vous ne savez pas encore c'est pas tout
à fait clair qu'on contracte et tous
peuvent poursuivre leurs activités
par contre qu'on demande aux
manufacturiers de réduire leurs
activités au minimum alors on sait que
certaines entreprises ont des carnets de
commandes qui sont très plein travail
difficile mais c'est vrai que pour d'eau
c'est une période qui est peut-être un
peu plus difficile il a - commande la
demande mondiale est à la baisse
donc c'est des entreprises qui pourront
potentiellement répondre à la demande du
premier ministre ce soir confinement
prolongée jusqu'au 8 février pour les
commerces jugés non essentiels monsieur
deux roues est votre réaction
mais écoutez les détails un nombre un
terrier l'enjeu de la situation par
contre comme comme moment de fermeture
c'est vraiment pas le moment idéal pour
le commerce de détail a quoi comme
période au royaume de mojo ravi de cette
une période où les générer des
liquidités par les liquidations qui sont
faits pour pour délimiter liquidités qui
sont importantes pour les périodes plus
de raquel de février mars et aussi pour
les achats du printemps le qui s'en
viennent qui ont commencé à vraiment
mais est-ce que vous jugez créé c'est
injuste pour les détaillants de devoir
fermer parce que je regarde les
statistiques pan de parler avec madame
pro également du côté du secteur
manufacturier a quand même des éclosions
un secteur manufacturier de co vides il
y en a pas mal moins
commerce de détail est ce que vous
trouvez vous êtes traité injustement
écoutez c'est difficile à évaluer mais
bon on n'est pas des experts en santé
publique on a fait notre point par
rapport justement au rire à la rigueur
des commerçants dans l'implantation des
bases erronées au faible nombre de cas
sylvie en avant la santé publique a
décidé que dans le contexte actuel puis
qui est quand même assez urgent d'agir
donc on est conscient que on a notre
part à faire on a quand même
l'opportunité maintenant au moins de
faire de ramassage en magasin ce qui
devient aussi une petite porte de sortie
intéressante de vaud plusieurs
commerçants qui vont pouvoir se garder
la tête hors de l'eau avec l'impérial
urnes au mac os x on n'est pas dans la
bouffée d'air frais l'acquis woerth qui
va relancer ces entreprises là cela dit
oh non pas du tout dans le code commerce
de détail de ces vraiment un petit peu
pour être capable de se garder la tête
hors de l'eau mais aussi répondre aux
besoins des commerçants des
consommateurs la période de fermeture de
deux semaines était quand même tolérable
de produits les consommateurs et melilla
des besoins et qui vont commencer à
s'écrire le but sur jonah dépôt du nom
essentiel de répondre à ces besoins
d'eau et où son petit commercial qui
vont pour compétitionner avantage est
carrément s'assure en bordure de madame
pour je vous pose une autre question
avant que vous alliez vous occupez la
marmaille
on a vu d'importants foyers d'éclosion
dans le secteur de la transformation
alimentaire
il y tout de même on imagine assez
difficile de fermer des usines de
transformation des abattoirs qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec cette situation il ya
quand même eu pas mal de cas et pas mal
d'éclosion dans les abattoirs tout à
fait puis on peut on comprend que la
majorité des explosions dans le secteur
manufacturier est relié à la
transformation agroalimentaire et plus
spécifiquement les abattoirs
nous ce qu'on demande au gouvernement de
pierre c'est de s'asseoir avec ce
secteur d'activité là avec les
entreprises qui sont plus touchés pour
voir comment on peut mieux les
accompagner mieux les encadrer pour
limiter le plus possible les foyers
d'éclosion
mais encore une fois et comme le docteur
arruda 9e enseigne au point de presse ce
n'est pas un secteur d'activité que l'on
peut fermer ce sont des biens essentiels
alors on va devoir on va devoir vivre
avec encore une fois nous on off
collaboration gouvernement pour mettre
en place toutes les mesures qui sont
nécessaires pour limiter des foyers
d'éclosion dans ce secteur le
gouvernement vous a entendu
l'amour il nous a entendus oui oui oui
tout à fait tout à fait on est très
heureux mais je voudrais que ce qu'on
veut éviter dans le fond c'est dans une
semaine au 2 août en un mois sont dans
un bois l'école continue à augmenter on
veut éviter que le secteur manufacturier
soit à nouveau interpellé mais ce qui
est important pour nous c'est de bien
comprendre ils sont où les foyers
d'éclosion et de travailler avec la
santé publique pour pouvoir les réduire
le plus possible parce que la situation
est ce que c'est un coup de grâce pour
les détaillants monsieur brou - compte
tenu que les détaillants ont quand même
beaucoup donné au cours de l'année 2020
ont vu beaucoup leur chiffre d'affaires
baisser
est ce que les prochaines semaines vont
entraîner selon vous des fermetures
importante c'est évident la période des
failles à porter ce qu'elles étaient
habituellement donc été quand même
correct pour plusieurs détaillants il ya
des secteurs qui ont travaillé dans
d'autres secteurs comme la mode la
chaussures les bijoux qui sont beaucoup
plus vulnérables présentement
et comme il a tantôt les enjeux de
liquidités ils vont vraiment prendre le
dessus et ceux qui sont plus vulnérables
on risque de revoir dans les prochains
jours dans les prochaines semaines des
détaillants qui vont se remettre en
protection de la faillite ou même aller
en faillite complète dont on ne souhaite
pas on espère que nous allons pouvoir
aider davantage comme ils font
présentement le québec doit augmenter
l'aide financière aux détaillants
écouter les programmes de base sont là
c'est des programmes de prêts d'argent
disponible les liquidités des
subventions salariales vont sûrement
pouvoir aider aussi dans le contexte le
programme d'ado loyers du fédéral qui a
été retravaillée de façon plus
accessible et facile qui vont être
disponibles pour les petits commerçants
donc on espère qu'après moi tout seul
cette enveloppe est capable de dévier
les détails elle a passé au travers puis
assurer la pérennité de ce secteur est
quand même un secteur important dans
l'économie du québec
merci monsieur drevet merci madame
prouve pour vos réactions ce soir à
chaud après ce point de presse du
premier ministre ne gros merci bonsoir
bonsoir